[Música]
no fue aprobado por ya aprobado en La
cámara imputada
pueblos indígenas en Brasilia y eso es porque
exigen que los grupos indígenas tiendan a
que prueban que estuvieron en la tierra y
en él 88 lo que ella hizo la condición
brasileño y este ejemplo es algo
muy difícil de probar porque primero
son grupos multilaser
[Música]
para muchos y más que eso se convirtió
Una realidad
si contaba entonces sus útiles le devolvían el
guerras después de ella Constitución
Brasileño garantiza el sonido de los Aéreos
derecho de la tierra para que usted que cerca
de leyes un proyecto muy serio porque
esta como
bolibindo detrás de él la construcción que
fue en la construcción que garantiza el terreno para
medicos indigenas y se oi tendremos
una cuarta parte fue una sonia
Brasileño totalmente protegido por
tierras indígenas que son las áreas
proteínas más eficientes para
defender la decoloración del estacionamiento
porque en los grupos que empujan las leyes
son superados por los agricultores
Brasil es un importante exportador de soja.
de más que otros con ojos agrícolas
Luego disputas por la tierra en
brasilia
entonces si muchos tenientes de tierra dejan eso
tiene que perder partes por la demarcación de
tierras indígenas porque
tierras indígenas que no eran
demarcadas y muchas de estas tierras fueron
indebidamente ocupado en muchos casos
por los pacientes para producir como antes
para exportar por muchos abrigos
Quiero de Echo cómo releer en las tierras que
las tierras que ya han sido demarcadas
existir para poder ampliar susqueiro
expande tus plantaciones y poder
exportar pero luquece en vigor y bruto si
si piensas
económico y sobre todo medioambiental
como todos sabemos en la masonería
su punto sobre el regreso está a punto de
mover una Savannah si posibilidad de
producir la Julia que alimenta la casa
toda la producción agrícola brasileña entonces
Tu mas
tierras agrícolas supondrán en un
Los futuros relacionados con una menor producción en el
tierras agrícolas y finas que ya son
influyendo en Brasilia y para Ouro
precisamente lo cerca que estamos
en estos momentos desde este punto de no
devolver
lamentablemente no hay mucha valla rosa
sabemos exactamente el cuadrado de ese punto
solo sabremos si pasamos y no
podemos pasar este punto mi
Los científicos dicen que más o menos.
entra cuando ahi le gusta esa amazónica
y atrapado entre Bento y el 95% ya no
habría más retorno eso es
evitar que se seque hasta convertirse en un ambiente
muy seco y luego tu si na
posibilidad
Uruguay y casi
perdimos más o menos
así en Brasilia principal pero no
no siempre funciona más o menos
Los científicos también, eso es lo que hay en la cima.
posibilidad de quién en los próximos 5
años pero 25 millones de hectáreas
La masonería no sólo
brasileños sobre
de la ganadería Largo y si eso pasa si
eso pasa por ahí si ya estamos como el
su punto sobre la devolución y por eso tendemos
muchos esfuerzos para reforestar parte
de la Masonería será muy difícil
evitar los impactos más duros para
principalmente para su agricultura cuando
América es sorda y precisamente tú.
esfuerzos para evitar
importante
marca temporal y por otros decir
que finalmente termina aprobándose que
otras alternativas de secretariado
Silva para avanzar en la protección
Allí, como un camino ancho para esto.
proyecto de ley se convierte en ley Entonces, si
convertirse
ser común en la semana y apreciado
dentro de ese cartel de senadores atados
agricultura para apoyar y rápidamente
Presente la señal de que esto no lo sabe.
que toca hablar mucho que toca
analizar mucho porque la zona de la ley es muy
serio y si la teoría de Proerd que presenta
Lula tiene erupción borra esta ley Y luego
que sería si las lacostes aprobadas
que presenta a Lula y en ese
momento en la base sólida en el Congreso
Nacional por lo que es posible que si
él es por ley que el congreso en
Cámara y Senado por tumbar en los betos
Entonces, si esto sucede, acude a los tribunales.
condicionado que en ese momento cuando
Tienes el ganado al aire libre.
esta tesis telemarcotemporal para actuar en
persona nuevamente los gallo y esta con
un marcador teórico de estudiantes contra
marcó temporal por no terminar
Porque algunos con estos perforan más tiempo.
para analizar luego ser tomado como
pocos meses todavía
y donde no sé si les recordará que
entra es jair bolsonaro era presidente
desde Brasilia estudiando nuestro país como
Francés
estar protegido digamos por cual
internacional tan superficial
a mi me parece una iniciativa folklorica
este porque echado el barro ya esta
gobernados por muchos países que
Brasil Colombia Ecuador Perú Perú Bolivia y
todos estos países en los demás dependiendo
del mundo está interesada porque ella
moçonia es una reserva de carbono de gran tamaño
universidad
para todos para el abrigo para
en los demás eres el productor de un trío de
Argentina él productor de soja y
Productora de Maísa de Paraguay por
el ejemplo necesita caminar al albañil
Por que si en la masoneria asi julvia no
es producción
Entonces no hay economía en otros como
países somos enfermedad
tenemos que avanzar en forma de
proteína más pequeña y esto es muy urgente
Porque nos tendremos como menos a mí en la década.
para que esto suceda tienes algunos que
detener la expansión agrícola en ella
Bosque esto es súper posible porque en
Brasilia en Colonia de los paises que tenemos
cambiar las áreas ya abiertas ya le quedan bien
agricultura producida sí teme que ellos
Fue a ser unitario más que Bosque
y habrá que seguir adelante en sostener los pelos
pueblos indígenas en Bosque que
somos nosotros los que protegemos y necesitamos apoyo
a vivir juego a desentrañar
sus alternativas económicas y a veces
lo que necesitamos ser entonces tu
querían que resolviéramos esto
problema entre otros Por supuesto con el
ayuda internacional
si usted durante ese gobierno y
bolsonaro
era más o menos un clima terrestre
así ley en lamania todos los grupos
criminal nosotros ¿Qué tal
aquellos que roban tierras públicas para
Todas las actividades agrícolas se detuvieron.
si en un enfrentamiento de blogueros sin
no hay problema entonces si
tendemos a cronometrar los problemas para migrar en el
Masonería porque por ejemplo y en la tierra.
Indígena en mami también había Tem
mineros y legales para una población de
menos de 15 ml indígena para que usted
para ver el tamaño del problema y
cada minero ilegal es un daño
establecido tremendamente para ser muy poco en el
búsqueda de muchas investigaciones aquí en
Brasilia fue a ver cómo están los peces
y en los principales pilares de la Masonería
brasileño y encontró que una gran parte
Del pescado que produce, se come todos los
días en una mampostería importante no ha
La proteína de la pesca es una gran parte.
de pescado están contaminados por
La urania ilegal está contaminada con
Mercurio y mercurio una cosa que es.
contamina en renten para que estés ahí en
alta probabilidad de que muchos
nidos
están contaminados con ellos mucho ariba
de luz recomendada por la Organización
Organización Mundial de la Salud entonces tú eres una
problema ambiental ellos un problema
público y esto aumentó con bolsonaro
por Lula si la hora intenta morder
atrás es difícil para el finalmente se acumula
ley con esa policía cuando él está
descansa también ayudando y en la tierra y
anomame ya ha eliminado a la mayoría de los invasores
lo que tiene que ser entonces lo serás
como un regusto duro por al menos pero
hace aproximadamente 12
[Música]
en los bancos centrales de muchos países
como de Inglaterra y Estados Unidos
detina incluida porque todos comprando
oro en Brasilia comienza con oro
super descargable eres super facil el
que vendes como si fuera polvo fresco sin
ningún tipo de puesto y también ahí
muchos que compran por ejemplo alli solo irian
producido en áreas que estaban
desconectado legalmente que todo llega
mi europa o gerentina entonces tu
dejar un problema de un comercio
internacional y temíamos que se estrellara aquí
aguantar mucho
[Música]